>>WEO "STATE OF
THE UNION.
BE ESCATG
D AI ASE NORTH AND
SOUTH OF THE
DEIV INCLUDING
WOMEN AND A CHIL WHILE
>>> I WANT TGOT TO THE
MAYOR OF KYIV,I KLITSCHKO
AND HIHEVLADIMIR WHO
BEEN FIGHTING IN THE UKRAINIAN
ARMY.
MR. YO I'LL START WITH YOUIA A
S FROMS CITY CENTER.OWE
PHONE WITH YOU
ZELENSKYY.
WHAT DID YOUL HIM ABOUT THE RE T
>> WE ACTUALLY ARE UNDER 24 IP
MBATTACKRIT NORTH OF, AROUND5 M
CENTRAL KYIVTHE TARGET IS KYIV
RUSSIANS HAVE THIS TARGEWE, ANSY
WE DEFEND OUR , AND RIGHW HUGE,S
BE NEVER, EVERN HAND
RIGHT NOD HOUSES,
CHEN THE
FUTU OOUUNS MES EN OUT THERE FI
FELLOW UKRAINIANS CAN  OUTA SUC
FURTHER INTOF YOURCESS, FOR PLE?
>> THEOU
MON
GRTHERE ISHIT  SSIBLY CAN B THE
MEN AND  SR ANWE
THAT WWERE  SCHOOL.HERE OUR REL
BURIED IN GROUND.
HOME, ANTH
OTHER WAY THAT WE'RE GOING TO L.
AND WHY?BECAUSE THIS IS OUR HOM.
BLOOD. ND THE COUNTRLAST THE
>> ANDARDING M
H A LOT OF .
N LOSE --
VEP ANAT'S WHY WWHICH CA THIS
WAR IS THE UNIT OF
KRAINE. TOE PRESSURELICAPRSUNCPN
WE'RE Y IND.
NOT JUST FUR COT
WE'RFIHEE LUES, THE SAME PRILET
UNION, IN EUROPE AN
CATOTHE WORLD.
KYRNING THAT WHEOMANOUBO
CHEMICAL OR
BIOLOGICAL WEAPONS.HOW OUT ? YE
TOLD JUST T MILITARY
W WE SEE THOUSANDS OF
CIVILIANS AND ALSO CDIE.
WE
ON ARO WT KNOWLSED.
ISIN UKRAINIAN
POPULATION
THAT'S WHY WE DON' HOWHIR WIL
N
QUESTION, WE DON'T WANT TO GIVE
>> SAWE PLE QUESTION FOR
MAYOOF MELITOPOL WASSID SEPARATE
ARAYORL.
YOU ARA ?
>> YES, OF COURS
RIGHT NOERN IS
EVERY UKD 'S NOT
AGAINSJUST C OF GO THEE SHOULD -
IT'S A WAR AGAINST WAS
POAGT EVERY IAN.RRY ABOUT ME, .
M READY TO FIGHT AND READY THET
O
THAT, BUT EVERY UKRAT
RYKR>> THA YG
, MR VITALCOURSE, YOUR BER
EETING ON I
RAINE MORELY.